I have dreams I have been [ __ ] crazy
dreams I had a dream one time that me
and Elvis walked into his Patel room and
there were four dudes but [ __ ] right
just hear me were there we're just that
might be one of the best sentences ever
created thrown up in Burger King [ __ ]
shut the door and I looked at Elvis your
dream baby wake up you don't really flip
me out well not that the guys were but
[ __ ] right
no it was the product placement like
what the [ __ ] did Burger King do to get
it what if they figured it out and you
just don't know that there is way to
interject advertising into your dream in
the future right now it's like I got
more Chrysler's dream about the Elvis
and the buck [ __ ] ha ha no no no but
what if there's a possibility that some
that someone could insert a product
right into a dream right they could give
you a cheeseburger in that cheeseburger
with some experimental thing that would
make you think about Burger King in a
dream and see a burger in a dream do it
you could do it [ __ ] future it's
going Geico and [ __ ] but that doesn't
make any sense Geico yeah eat something
to have this happen to you we're still
missing my home so I guess we're
stumbling on something very brilliant
right now
[Music]